hello everyone and welcome back to the
video World Cup we are in the second
game of the classical time format it is
Magnus Carlsen versus pragnanda and it's
an an incredibly important match for
both of them for Prague it would mean
that he actually defeated Magnus Carlton
in a match and this is uh still
classical so it would mean that if he
wins this game it will mean that he
defeated Magnus Carlsen in a classical
match and for Magnus it's also
incredibly important because the fide
World Cup is the only tournament that
Magnus costs and never won aside from
okay the official random World
Championship but that's not technically
chess uh so now that being said let's
check it out and then we're gonna
discuss what happened in the game Magnus
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to E4 uh Prague replies with Pawn
to E5 he also weighed a little bit um
and make his first move like Magnus did
in the previous game Knight to a three
Knights the C6 and here are pretty much
no one uh could have anticipated this
everyone thought okay it's either gonna
be a joke piano although not very lucky
probably a real Lopez but no Magnus goes
for Knight to C3 the three Knights
opening which always almost exclusively
means the Four Knights game so Prague
was nine to F6 and the bishop to B5 the
Spanish variation of the Four Knights
and frog goes Knights to D4 this is a
so-called Rubenstein Gambit and should
white accept this Gambit it can be a
very very exciting game for example if
Knight captures an E5 you grab the pawn
then you get Queen E7 attacks the Knight
and once the Knight moves you're gonna
pick up the bishop here let's take out
his captors and queen captures an E4
with check uh Queen to E2 and not a lot
Happening Here uh so uh that's one way
to do it but capturing an E5 will just
give black a very nice game so instead
we have Knight captures on D4 by Magnus
and now e captures on D4 we have Pawn to
E5 now offering to trade Knights and
praga obliges with d captures and C3 e
captures on F6 and queen characters on
F6 already uh he has a queen in the game
and here comes the captures on C3 and of
course it seems like Magnus just
blundered a piece here because why not
just deliver a check and pick up the
bishop here well if you do this queen to
E5 check it will be met with a bishop to
E2 or simply Queen to E2 which will also
guard the bishop here so here we have
Bishop to C5 even though Queen to E5
check is the most played move here
Bishop to C5 does seem to be a bit more
aggressive we have Queen to E2 with the
check and now comes Queen to E6 blocking
check with the queen and offering a
queen trade and it doesn't look like all
that much for Magnus he just uh trades
Queens it will be the exact same
material on the board with Magnus having
his Pawn structure messed up so not
something you want to look for if you
are if you are looking for Advantage
with white out of the opening but even
more interestingly uh the game uh this
exact same position has been reached in
2011 in a game between Nigel short and
Vladimir kramnik and the short actually
lost this with White's the comic in the
London chess classic but okay uh that
was a long time ago and that was very
Vladimir kramnik we have Bishop to F4
now Magnus continues developing and now
Queen captures an E2 uh the Queens get
traded off the ball we have characters
captures and I'll probably definitely
took his time here he wanted to make
sure that he's not missing anything as
the bishop to F4 line isn't played as
often as that Queen to E5 line that we
mentioned so C6 chases away Magnus is a
bishop Bishop to D3 and pawn to D5 and
now although you could play a for you
could play B4 Magnus plays Pawn to C
form uh looking uh for ways to get rid
of his Double C Pawn uh and okay we have
D captures on C4 Bishop captures and now
Bishop to F5 that cannot be played as
the bishop moved and Rook H to D1
uh getting the Rook to the the opend
file and of course uh do you do capture
on uh C2 that's the question well it of
course can be played but after capturing
and C2 then Rook D to C1 will be played
attacking the bishop and once the bishop
moves doesn't really matter where then
you have all sorts of discoveries with a
nice root captures on C5 afterwards even
a nice Bishop captures an F7 can be
played and then Rook captures on C5 so
again nothing spectacular here this is
still a dead draw so instead we have
Castles by Prague and now busher back to
D3 offering a trade of light Square
Bishops Bishop to E6 proc declines and
now King back to F1 with rook fpe8 and
pawn to B3 preparing Pawn to C4 uh we
have Rook 838 Pro gets his works on the
only two open files on the board the DND
file and Rook to E1 you have to make
room uh for the uh A1 Rook with Ponte H6
and The Rook 8 to D1 so exact same
material exact same Pawn structure exact
same uh like the exact same material
both players have a bishop pair and a
rook pair King to f8 and now Pawn to F3
with Bishop to B4 attacking magnus's
Rook here Rook to E4 attacking the
bishop with Bishop actor C5 and Rook DTE
E1 now Magnus doubles up on the E file
Bishop to D5 and now we have a trade
Rook captures Rook captures and Bishop
back to F5 uh Rook captures anyone with
check King characters and King the E7 so
now again the exact same material six
pawns each uh a bishop pair uh two
Bishop pairs each with one to see four
chases away the bishop Bishop to E6 and
Magnus trade with captors captures and
pawn to H3 Pawn to H5 stopping Pawn to
G4 and now King the E2 we have won the
G6 and he was in this position on move
30 that Magnus and Pregnant agreed to a
draw as there is nothing more to be done
here so why did Magnus do this with the
white pieces why didn't he try to you
know uh make it a seven hour game try to
torture progress long as possible try to
find some sort of a position that you
can play endlessly until until he breaks
Prague well there are two possible
reasons one although not a very likely
one is that he hates classical chess so
much one of the reasons why he's not
defending his wheelchair championship
title that he wanted to take this match
into Rapids and then possibly even Blitz
and show that he's uh the greatest
player in all time formats but like I
said very unlikely the other possible
reason is that as he already mentioned
in an interview with fide after his
previous game he had food poisoning and
he wasn't feeling all that great and you
know it a seven hour game isn't all that
great I imagine when you're suffering
from food poisoning if you haven't seen
this interview it's a very short do
check it out I will put a link to it in
the description below will be the first
thing you see so you know you can also
check that out as well but yeah this is
the second classical game between Magnus
and Prague somewhat squandered the white
pieces there but uh what are you gonna
do uh there obviously is the reason uh
and we're uh well I mean I'm not that
I'm actually very happy that we are
going to get another day of Chess and uh
today we could only get one game if the
match ended the match and but tomorrow
it is possible it's possible that we get
as many games as possible because uh
you're gonna have two rapid games of 25
minute format two rapid games of
um 10 minutes format then you're gonna
have two Blitz Games of five minute
format that's already six games and then
you go into sudden death where the first
player that wins just wins it all so we
could have many many games tomorrow and
I am very happy for that uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it and a little bit of extra info about
the food poisoning like I said first
link in the description below I would
like to thank Robert Bloom uh girls
nichesfestival.org Phil Malthus uh
France pancreat uh and David Kimura for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon most likely with the
coverage of the game abaso versus uh
caruana once it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day